pour en parler denis gravouille
secrétaire général de la cgt spectacle
est avec nous en direct sur air fait rt
france denis grave où ils merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors on le
disait emmanuel macron s'est exprimé
pour dévoiler son plan pour la culture
il souhaite notamment une année blanche
pour les intermittents ou encore
l'ouverture du fonds de solidarité
le chef de l'état at il a répondu à vos
inquiétudes
avec ces mesures bonjour il a répondu
partiellement il ya une très forte
mobilisation du monde du spectacle et
notamment des artistes et techniciens
intermittents du spectacle avec des très
grosses pétition pour dire nous ne
voulons nous voulons vivre de nos
métiers et donc il faut prolonger les
droits au delà des trois mois qui avait
déjà été annoncé alors donc il ya une
annonce de prolongation jusqu'au 31 août
2000 21 mais nous sommes très très
prudents parce que au-delà de l'annonce
on veut voir comment ça va se mettre en
oeuvre
la méthode est assez curieuse le
président reçoit 12 personnes triées sur
le volet des artistes connus valeureux
qu'on aime bien mais qui ne sont pas du
tout représentatif comme le sont nos
organisations de l'ensemble de la
profession et surtout qui nous nous
avons travaillé sur des propositions
précises qui font pas uniquement des
annonces donc donc on pense que nous
avons que les professionnels ont gagné
grâce à la mobilisation mais mais il
faut être très prudent sur le détail
pour les interviews spectacle et puis on
peut parler dans le détail
évidemment du reste des mesures qui sont
très importantes et pour l'instant qui
sont assez floues il faut bien le dire
c'est quoi le prends le plan de relance
pour la culture c'est quoi le plan de
reprise ce sont deux questions
distinctes à la reprise dans lequel
conditions sanitaires et la relance de
façon à pouvoir retrouver une activité
normale
on va y revenir sur ces mesures mais
avant peut-être sur la forme comment est
ce que vous vous comprenez que ce soit
emmanuel macron qui répondu directement
à ces douze artistes et non pas le
ministre de la culture
le ministre de la culture était présent
avec le président de la république
donc on sait que les politiques
culturelles il faut qu'elles soient
défendues
c'est toujours un peu véhicule par les
ministres du budget com
émise de l'économie comme un comme un
poids alors que c'est un secteur
économique aussi très important et puis
surtout ça un important ce fameux
extraordinaire dans la démocratie dans
la vitalité est là depuis depuis trois
mois quasiment tout est arrêté on ne
peut pas faire de spectacle donc donc
c'est logique que le président de la
république et le ministre de la culture
fassent des annonces par contre ce qui
est moins logique c'est qu'il le fasse
en n'ayant pas organiser une
concertation avec ceux qui les
représentent de façon générale et c'est
bien pour ça qu'on va être très très
prudents sur la mise en oeuvre de ces
annonces très vigilants ce que vous nous
dites c'est que vous n'avez pas été
consultés vous en tant que secrétaire
général de la cgt pendant toute cette
période de confinement ou les
intermittents étaient inquiets on a été
consultée parce que on a eu des
discussions avec le ministre de la
culture
mais la ministre du travail avait
annoncé des négociations sur l'assurance
chômage par exemple pour l'instant elles
n'ont pas commencé
donc c'est un peu curieux et donc plein
macron il fait des annonces
tant mieux si ça se traduit des faits
mais ça serait beaucoup plus simple
beaucoup plus clair si on avait pu
préciser exactement à travailler
discussions dans les dents les cadres
normaux tous les points je pense juste
un exemple
il n'a aucune nouvelle pour les nouveaux
entrants par exemple tout ce qui allait
démarrer ou qui avait commencé à
travailler la profession pour là dessus
ça n'a pas été évoquée où ça a été
évoqué comme on va aider les jeunes à
démarrer à la pour ceux qui sortiront
des cols en septembre on a absolument
besoin de discuter dans le détail des
propositions pour qu'on n'oublie
personne
justement jallet l'évoqué est ce qu'avec
ces mesures il ya il y a des oubliés
parmi les intermittents vous venez de
parler de ces jeunes qui sortaient des
cols est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres qui ne
seraient pas concernés par ces mesures
ou en tout cas qui n'aurait pas plus
d'être que cela avec ces mesures il y a
beaucoup de choses à regarder parce que
non seulement il ya les artistes et
techniciens interne les respectacles
mais il beaucoup de monde qui travaille
qui ne sont pas sous le régime des
intermittents assurance chômage se
souhaite d'ailleurs c'est valable pour
tous les travailleurs précaires qui pour
lequel n'y a pas eu d'annoncé pour le
moment et pour lequel le gouvernement
veut durcir les droits donc en septembre
donc ça c'est hors de question pour nous
et ça concerne par exemple des gens qui
travaillent sur les festivals qui sont
pas interdites en mai
les personnels qui travaillent sur les
festivals de façon saisonnière et tous à
tous toutes ces personnes là il faut
effectivement que qui est qu'on leur
vienne en aide puisque leur travail est
annulée de fête du fait de la pandémie
et puis on peut aussi penser aux autres
hisser aux auteurs qui ne sont pas
salariés et qu'il faut absolument
soutenir lors il ya eu des annonces du
ministre de la culture dans la foulée de
celle du du président et ses annonces il
faut qu'elles soient précisées parce que
pour l'instant c'est flou en quelques
mots justes pour conclure il nous reste
quelques secondes pour le chef de l'état
il faut que les lieux de création
revivent en s'adaptant aux contraintes
comment aujourd'hui le monde du
spectacle peut-il se réinventer les deux
questions il ya la reprise dans les
conditions sanitaires comme tous les
travailleurs
c'est difficile de reprendre le travail
en n'étant pas sûr de pouvoir le faire
dans de bonnes conditions et en plus ce
sont des lieux qui accueillent du public
pour beaucoup et donc ça ces questions
là doivent être traitées et c'est pour
ça qu'on demande un comité sanitaires et
sociales et puis à la question de la
relance et ça va prendre beaucoup de
temps
et là il a été dit que il y aurait un
soutien via la politique publique ont
dit banco mais on demande à voir
merci beaucoup denis gravouille d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général de la cgt
spectacle